merci madame la Présidente je voulais en
fait parler plus globalement de
l'article 8 en par parce que vous nous
en avez privé au tout début avec vos
artifices et votre volonté de nous
bâillonner au niveau des de nos prises
de parole au début sur
elle vous parlez
des amants
voilà et je vous remercie de laisser le
calme qui règne là dans l'hémicycle je
vous rassure c'est en lieu
donc en tout cas c'est pas la présidence
qui parle c'est la présidence de la
droite on dirait mais bon
on voit dans en tout cas
vous pouvez demander une suspension de
séance je chanterai je reprends la
parole monsieur chanterelle
monsieur chanterelle s'il vous plaît
je reprends la parole jamais vous
pourrez dire ça jamais tant mieux
pour tout le monde merci alors
maintenant je vous demande de faire
votre intervention et d'essayer de
garder le calme
alors
votre intimidation ne marchera pas merci
vous je sais que vous essayez je sais
que vous essayez de nous baïonner de
nous intimider de plus plusieurs depuis
hier mais vous ne priverez pas les
français du débat
que ça soit à travers les coups de force
que vous faites depuis hier nous
continuerons nous continuerons à les
défendre même si ça vous plaît pas c'est
ça la démocratie il faut l'accepter donc
donc je par contre j'ai par contre j'ai
été coupé d'une minute mais bon
ce qu'il faut retenir justement de cet
article de du recul de l'âge de départ à
la retraite à 64 ans
je vais demander une suspension de
séance madame la Présidente
c'est c'est que le recul de là ce sont
les plus fragiles justement ce dont
parle l'amendement de Monsieur Savary et
les plus fragilisés qui seront punis par
par cette réforme et au premier chef
celle et ceux qui bénéficient d'une
retraite anticipée comme il reste pas
beaucoup de temps je vais prendre le
temps par contre de les citer parce que
ce sont les personnes qui sont victimes
justement de votre de votre réforme ce
sont les titulaires d'une pension
d'invalidité les travailleurs déclarés
inapte au travail les allocataires de la
hache et de la location de cessation
anticipées d'activités les travailleurs
ayant eu une carrière longue les
travailleurs handicapés les travailleurs
qui ont une incapacité permanente à la
suite d'un accident du travail ou une
maladie professionnelle les
fonctionnaires handicapés les
fonctionnaires ayant eu
là c'est bon la parole est à Monsieur
karucci pour un rappel aux règlements
madame la Présidente j'avais dit ce
matin que j'espérais je vous remercie
d'avoir suivi tout de suite
je me permets de dire à Monsieur
chanterelle et à l'ensemble de nos
collègues que si le climat restait
celui-là il faudrait appliquer la
totalité du règlement et dans la
totalité du règlement monsieur Chantrel
il y a un article 95 qui dit très
clairement que toute provocation toute
atteinte à la présidence de séance
entraîne la censure voir l'exclusion du
Sénat
pour un rappel aux règlements
madame la Présidente je sais que vous
avez la faculté de savoir ce qu'il y a
dans les amendements avant même de les
lire c'est ce qui est arrivé hier avec
la présidente de roche déclarant une
erreur d'habilité sans même avoir lu nos
amendements et là vous avez eu vous la
faculté madame la Présidente de savoir
ce que notre collègue chanterelle allait
dire avant même de l'écouter parce qu'il
a juste dit qu'on voulait nous
bâillonner il a le droit de le dire et
la suite la suite
laissez parler monsieur Durin vous allez
jusqu'au bout mais je vous inviterai à
relire le compte rendu ensuite on
regardera la vidéo ensemble donc
la suite de la défense de l'amendement
la suite de la défense de l'amendement a
prouvé qu'on était bien sur le fond donc
je crois qu'il faut si vous voulez
effectivement éviter d'en arriver à ces
extrémités que nous promet monsieur
karucci on n'est pas obligé d'en arriver
là on n'est pas obligé d'en arriver là
donc je sais que politiquement ça
devient compliqué sur ce texte parce
qu'on voit bien on a regardé les
rectifications de vote ça s'effrite et
puis on voit bien ce que dit la presse
locale c'est pas très populaire votre
position on comprend votre embarras on
comprend votre armoire donc laissez-nous
travailler vous connaissez notre
attachement à cette maison à l'ordre qui
règne à la qualité des débats qu'on sait
produire ensemble donc si vous
contribuez au calme et si tout se passe
bien vous pouvez compter sur nous
merci monsieur Durand mais il faut voir
les provocation de huelvienne quand même
moi personnellement en tant que
Présidente je n'ai pas apprécié voilà
mes chers collègues je souhaite
sincèrement nos débats conservent la
sérénité qui fait la marque de fabrique
de notre assemblée et qui contribue à la
bonne image de nos travaux alors je
n'hésiterai pas afin de maintenir la
sérénité de nos débats à faire usage des
prérogatives que le règlement confère à
la présidence de séance et se rappelle
ayant été fait nous reprenons le cours
normal de la discussion